بالعوده الى الملف الاوكرانيه وتحديدا مع
اقتراب هجوم الربيع الموعود روسيا تتحضر
والدفاع الاوكرانيه يحاول اتخاذ وضعيه
الاستعداد وجمع ما تيسر من اسلحه غربيه
لكن نفاذ الذخيره يرافقه قصور بصفوف
القوات الاوكرانيه ما اوجد ضروره للتعبئه
العسكريه وفي وقت يستجيب بعض الاوكرانيين
للملصقات على الطريق السريعه والتي تدعو
المدنيين للانضمام للقتال وتحويل الغضب
الى سلاح تتسبب هذه المنشورات بتخويف
اخرين غير راغبين بالخدمه العسكريه وهنا
تبدا عمليات التجنيد رجال يرتدون الزي
العسكري يظهرون بكل مكان وفي اي وقت بحسب
واشنطن يطرقون الابواب او يقفون ويوقفون
المدنيين بشكل عشوائي في زوايا الشوارع
ويوزعون اوراقا قد تقلب حيات هؤلاء راسا
على عقب علما بانه في السابق كان بامكان
المسؤولين تسليم مسودات الاوراق فقط الى
منازل الاشخاص حينها كان يمكن تجنب
الاخطارات بتغيير عناوين السكن الرسميه في
المناطق الاوكرانيه هذا وتمنع مشاهدينا
الاحكام العرفيه المعمول بها في اوكرانيا
منذ فبراير من عام 2022 الرجال الذين
تتراوح اعمارهم بين 18 عاما وستين عاما من
مغادره البلاد كلها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات